Donald Trump has again commented on last
night's Democratic presidential debate
with a misspelled attack on the various
candidates this time focusing his ire on
Elizabeth Warren referring to her once
again as Pocahontas as well as talking
about Michael Bloomberg and Tom Styer
Tom trump starting bright and early this
morning with the tweets saying quote
crazy chaotic Democrat debate last night
fake news said Biden did well even
though he said half of our population
was shot to death would be over for most
Minnie Mike was weakened unsteady but
helped greatly by his many commercials
which are not supposed to be allowed
during a debate Pocahontas was mean and
undisciplined mostly aiming at crazy
Bernie and Minnie Mike they don't know
how to handle her but I know she is a
shocker steyr was a disaster who along
with Minnie are setting records and
dollars per vote just give me an
opponent now does this trump mean that
Warren is a joker and he misspelled it
or is Chalker sort of like cobb feffy a
word that Donald Trump
according through at the time Sean
Spicer that Trump knows what it means
and Trump's audience knows what it means
but I just am NOT in the know so I don't
know what it means that Warren is a
Chalker Trump also tweeting about the
corona virus and we are very quickly
learning and this is this is really
scary stuff we are quickly learning how
unprepared this administration is to
deal with coronavirus having all sorts
of people in important medical positions
and positions related to public health
that are interim people reducing funding
to many of the key agencies that would
be dealing with something like a corona
virus pandemic this is a real crisis
which we are going to be talking about
in more detail if the administration
doesn't get prepared for coronavirus
people will die who didn't have to die
and Trump is making it all a political
game saying quote low ratings fake news
MSDN C Comcast and CNN are doing
everything possible to make the corona
virus look as bad as possible
including panicking markets if possible
likewise they're incompetent do-nothing
Democrat comrades are all talk no action
USA in great shape I will be having a
news conference at the White House on
this subject today at 6 p.m.
CDC representatives and others will be
there thank you now we are not in great
shape and this is not political for me I
want to be in great shape no matter who
the president is just because it's not a
pandemic now doesn't mean it won't
become one but Trump only cares about
appearances how does he look at the
coronavirus context and and think about
it it's how did Obama do with Ebola
versus how am i doing with coronavirus
it's optics what kind of statements that
Obama may make versus what Trump is
doing this is sport for Trump it's Trump
coronavirus vs. Obama Ebola that's all
it is and that doesn't keep you safe it
doesn't keep me safe Trump then also
tweeting this morning just landed India
was great trip very successful heading
to the White House meetings and calls
scheduled today CDC and secretary Azhar
and all doing a great job with respect
to coronavirus briefing this afternoon
now of course if you watched our
coverage yesterday of Trump's trip to
India you know that it was yet another
embarrassment for Donald Trump Trump
showing up at a huge rally of a hundred
thousand Indian people mispronouncing
half of his speech while looking at the
teleprompter the way your dog looks at a
speaker that's playing a recording of
your voice and meanwhile half the crowd
as we showed you video of yesterday was
fleeing to the exits while drunk Donald
Trump was speaking followed by a press
conference in India during which Trump
said that Ruth Bader Ginsburg and Sonia
Sotomayor should recuse themselves from
any Supreme Court case even tangentially
related to Trump or his administration
we are living in idiocracy it was not a
great trip to India and we are
unfortunately it's happening to me too
we are desensitized to it a little bit
more every day so we'd better get re
sensitized to it and pretty quickly or
we are going to be very distraught
the results on November 3rd and we will
end up with another four years of this
atrocity we will of course see what it
is that Donald Trump says is that at
that 6:00 p.m. Eastern time coronavirus
briefing today but we are actually going
to be speaking to doctors specializing
in infectious disease about what is
going on with coronavirus who this may
not come as a shock to you know a lot
more than what Donald Trump has been
able to glean from the highly partisan
media that he consumes on a daily basis
one of our sponsors today is VIN Chara
watches giving you 15% off your entire
order when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch don't pay thousands of
dollars for a high-quality watch that
looks great because you don't have to
all of in Cera's watches are made with
high-end materials masterfully built and
they look like something you'd spend a
ton of money on but ever even chera
watch ranges from about a hundred and
fifty to three hundred bucks I went over
to their website and picked out the
bellwether in silver and white really
nice elegant look it's a coronagraph
style wore it to a gala over the weekend
and a lot of people ask me where's the
watch from really really great look
totally different they also sent me the
altitude in matte black and red a much
more rugged view of what a watch can
look like really liked it as well as
well as the athletic strap it's a new
year it's a new decade it's time to
re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch